what is it like working with the Jonas
Brothers going out on tour with them
it's Frizzle is an incredible
opportunity and I mean it's it's massive
it's a massive tour I mean it when they
first put the first tickets out and then
it just like exploded very well and they
had to add in more tickets I mean where
do you end up as fun they're like my
brothers
they're really cool I haven't met all
the wives is no I am I'm actually just
wanting to be friends with the wine I
just got the odds hanging out though
I've gotten to Game of Thrones so yeah
if Sophia Priyanka were shopping on
Sunday you should have joined them I
haven't met them yet look we like to get
her going slowly yeah you wait till
you're like actually best friends
offense okay all right so forget the
guys it's about the ladies yeah you'll
get in the dud
[Music]
you go out in that arena and you look at
it and you look at how these guys is
sustained for so long how they've done
that are you kind of in awe of how
they've been able to go from one
generation to the next
it's I mean what they've done is so hard
like that that rarely happens and I
think the fact that they were able to
have their big moment and then kind of
you know come it kind of take their own
ways and you know Nixon in his own thing
Joe did his own thing and now they're
able to come back Baker than ever is
that's not normal
like it's kind of incredible have they
done it I think I've been they we're all
patient that's all I think is key to
music and being in the music business is
not wanting just to go go go all the
time is riding the waves you tried to
set the internet on fire by putting out
that video with you in a wedding dress
in people took it a little crazy at
first what were you doing what did you
know that you were gonna make people
crazy well I don't think I was wearing
cutoff of gloves lace gloves I was
shooting a music video in London so I
didn't think people are gonna really
think that I would wear lace cutoff
gloves like from the 80s they believed
it so that was interesting but I was
kind of trying to we're training you
were trying to mess with people right
I'm sorry because you are always saying
some crazy stuff what crazy rumors about
who you're dating right it's definitely
I love that my butt is fake um by the
way is it weird as some of the rooms and
the people they try to put you in are
you ever like come on y'all stop
craziest why tell me crazy I just wanted
like somebody like that's like really
hot and like I don't know I just like
why can't me I don't know like I'm not
gonna go you know like the Brad Pitt's
of the world right right right
um but maybe I'm not there obviously I'm
not there you probably but um you know
II love you know the rumors too like
that but there's really nobody that like
I don't know that I would want to like
he like paired wits and I head over
heels off right now
so just stop oh Michael B Jordan Michael
B Jordan oh well ride many times as he
does I've tried what do you mean you've
tried
interviews and followed him yeah I think
I've gotten I've gotten like yeah he
definitely is not into it that's okay we
were just with him last night
I just want Mike it's okay come to the
concert at least right should be mutual
annoy fake show fire but you got a cold
you don't you do such a good job of
speaking out for women yeah you and I
love an article I just read where you
were like you really just told some
designers hey yeah I'm not playing this
game yeah where you want to want women
to be sighs zero to do stuff I think
inclusivity is really important yeah I
think that you have to like include all
women and not even women men as well um
I said a meet and greet you know ingress
me and green of the tour today and one
of the girls came up to me to start
crying and she's probably 15 so thank
you like you helped me love my body and
I just like wanted to cry because I was
like that's you know like you I say
things because it actually hurts me and
wouldn't you know when I'm for the
Grammys when a lot of the designers and
I want to trust me because I didn't fit
into their side zeros like there's
sample sizes that hurt me so that's why
I did that video and then I didn't Akana
as my therapy but I didn't know what an
effect it was gonna be on my fans and
women and men around the world so it's
kind of amazing like how you could use
social media to that platform so I gotta
be a little careful on what I say and do
that mmm also you have a big birthday
coming up on a xxx xxx what are you
gonna do for your birthday uh how crazy
is this come on I was born and raised in
New York and we're performing at Madison
Square Garden on my birthday August 30th
at I'm turning 30 how crazy is that
Wow I'm you don't understand how excited
I am so can we come hang out with you
then of course you're welcome we're
gonna have a big party afterwards what
come in with you we're gonna color I'm
releasing a song that day it's called
not 20 anymore because like I because
I've had and then in the music business
a lot of women know this I feel like a
lot of women here I go with my thing
Jesus or not but I just feel like
throughout my industry and in the
industry I mean and especially like
other women and other industry
I feel like a lot of times people are
very ages towards them you know we feel
like the pressure like we have to like
get to a certain place in our lives
because our eggs are gonna dry up and we
have kids and get married and get to a
certain age it's it's everybody laughs
but it's true and especially me being in
the music business like I've had
executives tell me like oh we like
you're 25 like you're getting old and
it's like now I'm 29 I'm about to be 30
like no I feel good look at JLo look at
cher look at I mean look at like you
know they're taking over the game so the
song is about being 30 and being a
better lover
mmm-hmm being a you know getting finer
like wine mm-hmm
and loving my 30s like I do things that
I could never do when I was
[Music]